do you have any thoughts about him are
you an a-rod fan at all growing up or
anything like that what do you think
about what he might bring to the team
a fan the baseball player
alex rodriguez yeah i don't know
yeah chris it's right now there's a
letter of intent that has been signed by
alex rodriguez and mark laurie
and what that means is they have a
30-day negotiating window
to get the final eyes dotted t's crossed
and go through the whole thing on the
1.5 billion dollar purchase price
but the unique thing about this setup is
that
the plan calls for alex and mark to
join the timberwolves ownership group as
limited partners
initially learn the ropes from glenn
taylor for two and a half years
and then eventually take over as the
majority partners they will still have
major influence assuming the deal is
finalized
on decisions and things like that but
glenn taylor really
didn't want to have a situation where he
just gave the team up
and walked off into the sunset right
away he wanted to stick around and help
mentor
the next group that comes in and it
looks like what uh is going to happen
here
any chance this new uh group moves the
franchise i know that was a point of
contention during the negotiations
listen every time that you have a new
ownership group that comes in especially
to an organization
that has struggled the way that the
timberwolves have you have to have
those questions asked right now from
everything i've told from sources on
both sides
of the equation on a rod and mark lori's
side on
glenn taylor's side all of the
discussions have been
they're keeping the team in minnesota
they're committed to making it work
in minnesota they want to invest in the
community here
they want to look at all sorts of
different things to improve this
franchise
and it was a major priority for glenn
taylor
to have a new partnership group that is
committed to minnesota he sees the
timberwolves
as a big part of his legacy here in
minnesota he wants them to stay here
ultimately over the long haul we'll see
but right now everyone is operating
under
the assumption that they're going to
keep it here